en 2001 dans le sud de la france
trente et une personnes sont mortes à
toulouse après l'explosion de 300 tonnes
de nitrate d'ammonium dans une usine de
fertilisants chimiques près de vingt ans
plus tard la même chose viennent se
reproduire au liban le nitrate
d'ammonium est une arme à double
tranchant
d'un côté c'est un fertilisant
terriblement efficaces sûrs
il risque toutefois de s'enflammer s'il
est exposé à des conditions
particulières à c'est un explosif
occasionnait tu veux qu'on déclenche
explosion va inévitablement tout le lot
qui est entreposé dans des sacs et puis
les uns sur les autres c'est tout le lot
qui veut qui va exploser
il peut aussi tomber entre de mauvaises
mains en 1995 timothy m'élever a tué 168
personnes à oklahoma city en faisant
exploser devant un bâtiment fédéral une
bombe fabriquée à partir de nitrate
d'ammonium que récemment en 2006
la gsr déjouer un complot terroriste en
ontario 3 tonnes de ce composé chimique
devait être utilisés pour attaquer entre
autres le parlement d'ottawa
au québec on a déjà utilisé le nitrate
d'ammonium comme arme lors de la crise
donc le blocage du pont mercier s'est
fait avec des rangées de sacs de nitrate
d'ammonium en 2013
un incendie criminel dans une usine
d'engrais où était stocké du nitrate
d'ammonium a également fait 15 morts
près de waco pour texas depuis beaucoup
d'agriculteurs se sont tournés vers
d'autres types d'engrais plus stable
fallait disposer de ce produit là avec
beaucoup plus de précautions que les
autres naturellement s'était gardé comme
un peu d'argent dans un simili banker
est là parce que même avant les
événements de walcourt on connaît le sel
l'extrême dangerosité de ce produit lolo
le nitrate d'ammonium continue toutefois
d'être importés entreposés et distribué
au canada
le port de montréal par exemple confirme
la présence de nitrates d'ammonium au
terminal de contrecoeur sur la rive sud
ces terrains sont loués à la norvégienne
ra qui l'utilisent pour la production
d'engrais le nitrate est stocké dans des
dogmes spécialement conçu pour ce type
de produits la manipulation est
l'ensemble des opérations sont encadrés
par des règlements fédéraux et
provinciaux fertilisants canada qui
regroupe les principaux joueurs de
l'industrie fait valoir que le canada
possède parmi les règlements et les
normes de l'industrie
les plus rigoureux au monde en matière
de sûreté et de sécurité des
fertilisants un des derniers incidents
et puis quand du nitrate d'ammonium au
canada est survenu en 2004 dans une mine
de l'abitibi témiscamingue
cette fois le produit avait été utilisé
comme explosif
un travailleur est mort six autres ont
été intoxiqués ici jérôme l'abbé radio
canada montréal